the US is investigating what caused
American diplomats in Cuba to experience
mysterious symptoms sources tell CBS
News that lawmakers were caught
off-guard by news of the illnesses which
included hearing loss members of the
House and Senate are now requesting
congressional briefings into what
happened Julianna Goldman is outside the
Cuban embassy in Washington Julianna
good morning good morning well this all
started late last year in Havana and now
there are many questions and not many
answers but in May the US did expel two
Cuban diplomats from here in Washington
our Americans were not safe they were
not secure obviously because something
has happened to them the State
Department won't confirm what caused the
ailments experienced by diplomats but
said the safety of US personnel is
paramount category commenting on Cuban
state TV the government denied any
involvement and called the removal of
Cuban envoys from the US quote
unjustified and baseless the ongoing
investigation is pointing to high-tech
sonic technology that can't be heard by
humans but is clearly harmful
investigators believe the device was
placed in or around the homes of US
embassy workers in Havana more than a
dozen staffers at the US Embassy in
Havana reported various symptoms from
headaches to sleeplessness to permanent
hearing loss security officials swept
the home of one Canadian diplomat who
experienced adverse health effects
everyone in that home including human
employees was hospitalized this also
impacted family members of the diplomats
and and I think that's even more
disturbing John Cole field was chief of
mission in Cuba during the Obama
administration he says when he was there
diplomats were recorded and filmed but
never harmed this occurred at a time
when relations had improved and so it's
it would be inconsistent with all the
other behavior that I saw by the Cuban
government to take action that would
would physically harm diplomats
intelligence experts we spoke with told
us that most likely what happened was
that this was an intelligence gathering
operation gone bad possibly by the
Cubans or it could have even been the
Russians or this also could have been
purposeful harassment of US diplomats
abroad but blabbed the State Department
and the FBI continued to investigate
Julianna Goldman thank you